ladies and gentlemen crack open your
celebratory drinks we've got breaking
news from The New York Times Vice is
said to be headed for bankruptcy the
company which was once valued at 5.7
billion has been struggling to find a
buyer this year in fact the reporting is
going to go to auction look at this Vice
I got 50 bucks
I offer stands 50 bucks Vice would
continue operating normally and run an
auction to sell the company over a
45-day period with Fortress Investment
Group in pole position as the most
likely acquirer
this is this is is amazing that's it
it's all coming Crashing Down it is kind
of sad I got to tell you when I when I
started advice it was not as bad as it
had become in fact it was quite good
Shane Smith the CEO had gone on Colbert
and said look we're not Democrats or
Republicans we're storytellers we're
just trying to you know figure this
thing out and I'm like that's amazing
the videos they were producing were just
like uh your bar buddy telling you a
story about how he walked through this
place here's what he saw there was no
pretense there was no Authority and then
as soon as they got money he said bring
in the pretense bringing the authority
and bring in the feminists and it burned
the company to the ground I gotta be
honest when Vice was sex drugs and rock
and roll and edgy it was skyrocketing it
was and the moment they decided to get
woke they went
yeah well it's like what Elon Musk was
saying about the woke mind virus you
know and it took over Vice and it
destroyed it took over BuzzFeed there's
nothing and it's basically like that's
the reason post-millennial exists
there's literally math this kind of
stuff yeah there's nothing cool about
woke right like it's cool to be nice to
people and and that's what you you know
you want to treat people with respect
and stuff I get it but there's nothing
edgy there's nothing cool about being
woke and vice's whole Foundation was
built on being edgy and cool they snuck
into North Korea like the whole point
was like they were balling like their
New York parties were always sexy and
really fun well I mean I never went but
it was uh you know it's like it's
supposed to be edgy and cool and then it
it's like all woke is is just like
society's Hall monitors and it sucks
because all they ever do is you can't
say this can't do that blah blah blah
and it's totally antithetical to what
Vice started out as it was supposed to
be the CNN of the street it was supposed
to be anti-establishment it was edgy it
was taking over and then as soon as they
got any semblance of of money
immediately Joe Biden's coming in for an
interview back the Obama Administration
we're going to get oh we're so excited
for this
they went full and just as soon as the
government came to knock him as soon as
the investor came to knock and they said
we will do anything you say and this was
inevitable yep now I'm sure they're
going to come out try and give you all
the reasons about well it's a changing
landscape and media no I disagree
there's a reason why Tim Cass is
expanding and vice is imploding and
BuzzFeed is imploding and there's a
reason why all these journalists are
just so salty I offer them jobs every
time do you really absolutely absolutely
but you know has anyone taken you up on
it uh there actually are people advice
who are good people who are just
documentary filmmakers who are like let
me know if you ever need a pitch because
you know we've always want to go and
travel and do some stuff
that's a nonprofit well the people there
who are good are the people there at
Vice who are good are going to find jobs
making things that are good instead of
that garbage and the people there who
suck and are dragging the company down
are gonna either change or they're not
gonna find work so that's the thing it's
creative destruction
I can't believe it's fine it it really
is sad I mean I looked at the old Vice
building for sale 34 million dollars oh
wow it's a compound in Williamsburg in
New York it's got a whole bunch of
business in it but man I I went and
looked at it since Vice moved to a new
building in South uh you know the
southern part of Williamsburg in New
York and uh the old buildings just
Fallen apart it's like nothing it's like
graffiti all over it I think a large
portion of it was actually torn down
yeah and it is I'm like man I'm looking
at the picture and I'm like I used to
stand out in front of there you know
just talking smack with other employees
all these stories talking news talking
politics finance and uh now it's all
just falling apart yeah and it's crazy
because I'm just thinking back to 20
2012 2013 when I'm like 2012 I'm talking
to these guys 2013 I'm getting hired
over there and they would not listen
but you know what
part of me I wonder is if Shane Smith
cares I think he does because brand was
always so important to him it was always
the most important thing to build up the
brand and I think he want advice to
become Disney to become CNN to be this
Legacy brand and because of his
inability to see what was happening
around him and his embracing of this
crackpot cult garbage he burned his own
name to the ground and now what does he
have to show for it well look he may
still be worth a lot of money but most
of his wealth was tied up in Vice so
when people said that he was a
billionaire it was only because of
vice's value at 5.7 billion he cashed
out I think like like 30 or 40 million
dollars maybe and now that Vice is
worthless and entering bankruptcy to be
sold I don't know how much I'll even get
out of this I think it is I think it is
too bad I always really liked their
photography and you know the like
edgy nature of it I thought it was fun
but though but those people who were
good at doing that they're gonna find
work they've got organizations that are
decent yeah exactly because if they
start something new themselves exactly
because with it with an organization
like this and this is part of why I'm
cheering it on it's not because I'm glad
that the people who are talented and
hard-working and dedicated are out of
work it's because all of those people
were locked into an organization with a
bunch of idiots who were woke and had no
idea how to direct the company and now
the workers who were genuinely good are
free to pursue opportunities at
companies that will guide them better
and lead them better or like you said
start their own businesses and I think
that's a beautiful thing yeah I think
it's always good to start your own
Enterprise one thing I mean at post
millennial I came on in 2019 as a
freelancer and now I'm like you know
your top dog part of running the company
and like I heard of you know I'm part of
running the company I don't don't try to
avoid accountability here all right
anyway but the uh the fun thing about it
and like a big part of the reason I
wouldn't want to go somewhere else is
like I've been working on it this whole
time I've been like making it with these
people that you know I really enjoy that
that work there and it's like we built
this thing why would we you know I would
never want to do something else like my
hands are stuck in the muck of this
project this may be one of the biggest
get woke go brokes we have ever seen
yeah pulled up a story from 2017 Vice
media's Shane Smith is now a billionaire
they said that due to a uh due to a
foreign 450 million dollar investment
round Shane Smith's Holdings were now
worth some 1 billion dollars they say
that he had roughly 20 percent of Vice
after applying a 10 private company
discount to its valuation and adding
Smith's spread of some 33 million
dollars in real estate his net worth
totals an estimated 1 billion if he had
20 percent of the company and that's
what put him at a billion dollars with
Vice currently going bankrupt his net
worth is now in the low tens of millions
ah he's broke he went I looked down on
him he has nothing tens of millions no
no no hold on he's he's got more money
than he could ever spend I'm sure he
even said he says in this he says I
don't give an issue about money I've got
more money I'm worth more money than I
can ever spend that's absolutely
absolutely true
so he's going to be able to retire very
very comfortably and probably be
independently wealthy for the rest of
his life he never has to work again but
going from being a billionaire running
one of the most valuable media companies
to losing all of that in a matter of a
few years all because they wanted to get
well and you know what they want to make
any excuse they can and I can prove
outright or I'll just say outright it is
BS Vice had no reason to lose its
standing it was the wokeness it is
divisive it splits your audience and
they hyper polarized they they basically
told everybody who ever liked Vice to f
off let me tell you a story about when I
was talking to one of my producer
buddies that I've known from Vice for a
long time Vice ran an article and it
said this horrible app can show you what
women look like topless and it said
someone developed it I remember this
developed an AI app that if it takes a
picture of a woman you can press render
and it will AI remove their top and I
said do you know what vice's headline
would have been in 2013 this amazing app
can show you any because they were
mocking they were trying to be edgy and
be like screw you can do it everyone and
they decided to get woke and be Hall
Monitor feminists and they basically
told their entire audience you are bad
people F off and I was told by this dude
advice well but we have to change we
can't do that anymore and I'm like then
you're gonna fail because you're not
going to be Vice I don't know right I
think exactly you are now trans Vice I
think it's fair to say that sucks though
I think it's fair to say that particular
app sucks but the point was it's not
that vice's old headline would literally
be intending to talk about how great it
is the app exists it was meant to insult
the established narrative and be edgy
and say screw your system
but instead they became Hall monitors I
mean I gotta be honest they probably
wouldn't have even written the article
they'd be like who cares let's complain
about how screwed up everything is and
tell everyone to go f themself sex drugs
and rock and roll instead they were like
let's put on our our button-up shirts
and then go complain about how
oppressive these people are
all they did was start pwning up to the
establishment narrative and people don't
care for that especially young people
but more importantly this is what Bud
Light did Vice went to their readers and
said now that we have investment we
don't care about you and we're going to
Target a different demographic and guess
what the younger demographic did not
care they did not care for the hall
monitor style of of content so they
don't like it I mean because because
what all of these wokie people and the
corporations don't realize is that they
are now the establishment and the kids
are coming up and they're looking at it
and they're going stop telling us what
to do stop telling us what to believe we
don't subscribe to your whole world view
we're going to bucket we're going to get
off this whole train and so that's what
they're doing like you know my son and
his friends they look at this stuff and
they see right through it they see that
it's total ideological garbage and they
want to make their own way they want to
come up with their own opinions and
ideas I have two teenage nephews and
they're the same yeah and I have mad
respect for these kids looking at being
like you are the establishment and the
Millennials didn't realize that when
they were buying into this whole
narrative it was the establishment
narrative you know and gen z i I think
we're still waiting to see what happens
with them but you know they're all these
this guy Sykes with the tampon guy and
all this stuff that's what they're doing
and they're getting all this money from
the Biden Administration now to to be
influencers as tend to start you know
spilling this garbage narrative oh yeah
did you see those yeah those two uh
Twitter guys the Gen Z
what's his name you know talking about
the two gen Z dudes who are making
videos where they're all smarmy and we
don't like the Republicans we're not
paid by the dance
and there's a community not being like
they're they're they're hired by a
management firm that's funded by the
dealership they're getting communities
the greatest trick The Establishment
ever pulled was convincing people that
it wasn't the establishment that was
really clever Obama did that he did an
amazing job and I gotta say we're
counter cultural because they liked the
president which is absurd I when I was a
teenager I found it very patronizing
when I would
have The Misfortune of seeing anything
on MTV because someone else was watching
it I would cringe because it always felt
very how do you do fellow kids and I
knew that these were adults writing he's
fantastic but I it was obvious that
these were adults writing young people
saying the things that these weird
creepy adults thought young people
should be saying so that I would watch
that and go that's so
that's so it made me extremely angry as
a youth and unfortunately now they have
this edge of being able to promote
whichever voice they want through the
algorithm on Tick Tock because sure
you're always going to find young people
who are mixed up and will repeat these
talking points and because it's not as
highly produced because it's not clearly
coming from Hollywood right or the
establishment young people yes it seems
organic and it seems like something the
majority of young people actually
believe because it's continually
recommended by the algorithm and it's
possible that among that generation
that's true but regardless my point is
the propaganda catches on more easily
when it's your fellow young people
saying it and it's promoted as opposed
to a highly produced television show
that I know is being written by people
in their 40s right it's it's very
produced it's extremely uh it's it's
it's very much the algorithm pushing
pushing the ideas that that I don't
think that are actually popular with
people like I don't like proof but yeah
I don't think that I think that it's uh
Shadow and zero hips Bust or butt are
evidence that none of this stuff
with young people that I mean yeah I
think they reject it and I think that
that's what I think too when the more we
see like I was writing about this
recently I've been giving a lot of
thought the uh the current beauty
standards are more unhealthy and
unattainable than the previous ones they
were the rejection abuse are we supposed
to look like Elliot page and get our
boobs off are we supposed to look like
lizzo and gain I don't know like a lot
of weight it's a rejection
she's obviously very beautiful like
she's a she's a woman but I heard I
heard Jared Leto in her face she's was
trying to gain weight for a roll so he
would take a pint of Ben and Jerry's
every night microwave it and then pour
olive oil and soy sauce and start up and
then chug it crazy
ice cream he gained weight so fast that
he couldn't stand and he had to use a
wheelchair
I remember very distinctly I used to eat
a pint of ice cream every day when I was
in college
I was stoned
but I realized very at a certain point I
was like wait I'm gaining weight I
really and I switched to a half pint and
I stopped getting dude I one thing I
thought in college that's College I'm
I'm finding a lot of people that uh I've
known and a lot of personalities that I
used to you know watch when I was going
to pro skateboarders musicians are
becoming more conservative
and they had no like I think there's a
rejection of what the left is doing to
the point where you've got edgy Urban
liberal types who are just like y'all
have lost your minds and now they're
like people need to have families and
and get jobs and they used to be the sex
drugs and rock and roll people and
they're just like none of this is okay
it's it's gone too far the
degeneracy is literally destroying
companies I'm not going to name anyone
specifically but there are some famous
skateboarders and musicians who are very
much from the world of sex drugs and
rock and roll who are now like have a
family buy property work hard save for
the future and I think it's because
they're they're looking into the mirror
that is the left and being like nah
that's how I ended up over here too I
know guys like you know I'm I'm
perfectly happy to be liberal a bit
libertine but I don't think that that
should be the social ethos yeah well
this is one band All That Remains yeah
very often you know it's normal that as
people get older they do tend to become
more conservative part of what's so
Insidious now is that people on the left
are encouraging these young people to
receive body mutilating surgeries that
they will not be able to reverse and
part of what ends up happening as a
result of that is a person is so bought
into it that they can never admit it was
wrong
among other many horrible yeah well
let's utilize your body how do you come
back from that thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8 pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time